thank you
[Music]
today we cancel a tick tocker by the
name of Jordana Grace now as far as I
could tell based on the 35 seconds of
research I did in preparation for the
segment Jordana is an unmarried
childless woman in her 30s
um from the looks of it uh and no reason
to make fun of someone because of that
there are people who are unmarried and
childless in their 30s through no choice
of their own but if you're unmarried no
matter your age
the situation calls for some humility
there there is obviously quite a lot
about dating and relationships that you
don't understand yet because you haven't
made it to the next level so if you're
wise
and if you don't want to be single and
lonely for your entire life you'll
listen with an open mind to the insights
and advice of those who have made it
farther down the road than you
and you'll especially listen to the
voices of your ancestors who lived at a
time when most people managed to get
married much younger and they stayed
together much longer they stayed
together in fact in most cases until
death
because these were people who were bold
enough to take the marriage vows
seriously rather than treating them as
we do like a series of meaningless
bumper sticker slogans
but listening humbly does not appear to
be jordana's strong suit and so she has
made a series of viral Tick Tock videos
where she mocks 1950s dating advice I
believe she got this list from a
magazine article from 1958 and it's
absolutely hilarious she thinks let's
listen
ladies I found the handbook
[Laughter]
from 19
th he posted 129 ways to find a husband
here are the top tips number 17 be nice
to ugly men because handsome is as
Hansen does
number 23 go to all your high school
reunions because it could be winter was
there
number 30 learn to paint and set up an
easel outside of an engineering school
number 25 go back to your hometown
because the Wild Boy make because the
Wild Boy Next Door might now be an
eligible bachelor number 33 carry a hat
box
number 38 drop a handkerchief it still
works
[Music]
beautiful or a Band-Aid so we can also
can ask what number 40 is the best stand
in a corner and cry softly because I'll
come over and ask what's wrong
let me just add one more tip right from
the outset
um do not cackle condescendingly like
some kind of smarmy hyena
ladies I'm telling you that there is
nothing less attractive to a man than
fake pompous
shrieking patronizing laughter
now men are famously visually oriented
if you're if you are if you are
physically attractive it is relatively
difficult to lose attractiveness points
in our eyes but condescension in general
and especially condescension in the form
of an annoying laugh that'll do it it
causes within us a reaction of of actual
physical revulsion
so just don't do it it's not worth it we
love your warm genuine laughter we hate
the fake disdainful I'm better than you
left so keep that one bottle up bottled
up if you can
but what about this advice from 1958
uh Jordana finds it hysterical now she
hasn't found us out her found a husband
herself yet but she's quite sure that
these tricks of the trade are laughably
absurd and I admit that through a modern
lens
some of them do seem kind of funny but
let's drop that modern Prejudice for a
moment and take a look at them again
so first it says be nice to ugly men now
as an ugly man myself I may be biased
but this seems like worthwhile advice to
me in fact you should be nice to
everyone as a default until they give
you a good reason to act well otherwise
because men are attracted to nice women
I might maybe that's like breaking news
these days but it's true
as previously covered there is no
personality trait in a woman that we
find less attractive than rudeness and
condescension
despite all the modern propaganda
telling women to be tough hard-edged
girl bosses quote unquote the fact is
that men still prefer women who are kind
and empathetic and warm and feminine
also on the subject of ugly men in
particular it's worth keeping in mind
that men will often hit their Peak
physically mentally financially later in
life so from a woman's perspective a man
might be at his most desirable in his
30s 40s even 50s there has been many a
man written off as ugly and undesirable
in young adulthood who later checks
every box so that seems to be part of
what this piece of advice is hinting at
um and I think this also mostly explains
explains the advice about going to high
school reunions and returning to your
hometown though both of those are
perhaps Irrelevant in modern times
because many adults never leave their
hometowns and social media has made High
School reunions mostly obsolete I guess
you don't need to go to the reunion to
see who got rich and who got fat you
know Facebook for that what about the
advice urging single women to uh set up
easels outside of an engineering school
now
I'm not sure that I would
choose an engineering school necessarily
as Engineers tend to be sort of weird
but the general strategy is quite
ingenious because men are attracted to
women with artistic talents that we we
like that we you know we don't much care
about the money you make or how far
you've climbed on the corporate ladder
but we do find artistic talent
interesting and this certainly works in
the reverse too probably more so
the fact is that whether you're a man or
a woman you'll be seen as more beautiful
if you can create beautiful things
and talent whether artistic talent or
any other kind of talent is attractive
in general to everybody
the rest of the advice all falls into
the same category you know wear a
Band-Aid cry in a corner carry a hat box
you might even try doing all these
things at once now I can't
personally endorse the strategy because
it's a little bit too dishonest and
manipulative for my taste but I can't
deny the potential effectiveness of it
either
see the point is to ignite a man's
chivalrous side
give him a reason to help you
I assume the idea behind the hat box is
that you know man might offer to carry
it for you and a hat box is I I don't
know if I've ever seen a hat box but I
guess it's like pretty big and kind of
cumbersome but it's light
so that makes it easy like a man can
offer to help it for you but it's not
gonna be too heavy for him and he can
feel like he's doing something
now I would perhaps update this to a
more relevant object for the Modern Age
though a hat box would have the
advantage of being an interesting
conversation starter it would give a man
a chance to ask questions like why did
you buy this large hat
why are you carrying it around in a box
rather than on your head where are you
going with the hat what will you do with
it when you get there
many successful relationships have begun
with hat related conversations of this
sort
now as for standing in the corner and
crying or faking a physical injury
these are tactics as old as time itself
men want to be able to help they want to
use their masculine energy in that way
there's a reason why the storybooks
Through the Ages have always told of men
rescuing damsels in distress a man wants
to be a hero
and if you can give a man that
opportunity hopefully in a less
deceitful way it will benefit both you
and him
the point is to encourage those nobler
more chivalrous impulses
and if such strategies are less reliable
in modern times it's only because men
have been increasingly conditioned to
suppress those masculine impulses
on the basis that chivalry is toxic and
patriarchal now so it may be true that
in some places in our country today blue
States mostly a woman could cry in the
corner and no man will come to her to
her aid but if that's the case it's an
indictment on our culture not on the
culture that produced the dating advice
that this woman is mocking
and whatever you think of the advice
it is certainly better than the than the
list of advice that our culture would
come up with
I'm so think about it a modern list of
dating tips for women would sound
something like this
number one uh totally neglect your
physical appearance fat is beautiful
body positivity means destroying your
body on purpose you go girl
number two swear off having children
make sure every every man knows that if
he ends up with you his bloodline will
die with him men just they love that
not going to leave a legacy behind that
they they can't get enough of that
number three family life is oppressive
and archaic so divorce devote yourself
fully to uh your employer instead
men are sexually attracted to ambitious
career-minded women most of all that's
what they want the most
number four the more bitter and
disdainful you are the better and then
finally
um number five you don't need no man
so make sure men know that you don't
need them
men love to not be needed
the more useless you make a man feel the
more attracted to you he will be
that's that's the modern list
and it's a list that would Garner full
approval on tick tock among women who
have never been in a successful romantic
relationship and probably never will be
because they literally laugh at wisdom
in the words of scripture professing
themselves to be wise
they become fools
which is why in the much less eloquent
words of the Matt Walsh show
they are canceled
well before you go uh hit the Subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe you can also
catch my show on Spotify Apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now I demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated